acne is a skin disease consisting of
blemishes that can occur on your face
neck chest shoulders and back
me is very common during the teen years
but it can affect you during adulthood
as well
to keep your hair and skin well
lubricated your body depends on
sebaceous glands which sit just under
your skin these glands secrete an oily
substance called sebum which coats your
skin and hair to prevent them from
drying out sebum travels up hair
follicles and out through your pores
onto the surface of your skin your hair
follicles routinely shed dead skin cells
which sebum carries out of your body
when your body produces extra sebum and
dead skin cells they can stick together
and clog your pores resulting in skin
blemishes
then bacteria that normally exists in
small amounts on your skin can flourish
in the sebum in the clogged pore leading
to inflammation
depending on where the clog is located
and if you have inflammation acne may
appear as white heads which are clogged
follicles closed off from the air
blackheads which are clogged follicles
that turn a darker color when the clog
is exposed to air pustules commonly
called pimples which are inflamed
follicles clogged with pus or cysts
which are larger painful pus filled
lumps going deep under the skin
hormonal changes particularly a rise in
testosterone can lead to sebum
overproduction which is why acne often
occurs during the teen years however it
can occur at any age other factors
contributing to the development of acne
are bacteria certain medications and
genetics if you have a mild case of acne
your doctor may recommend and
over-the-counter lotion with one of
several active ingredients
zoil peroxide kills bacteria dries
excess oil and removes dead skin cells
clogging pores salicylic acid slows the
loss of skin cells to prevent clogged
pores it may also break down whiteheads
and blackheads
the hydroxy acids such as lactic acid
help remove dead skin cells reduce
inflammation and stimulate the growth of
new smoother skin sulfur removes dead
skin cells and dries excess oil
these are strong chemicals that may
irritate your skin follow the directions
for use exactly
if over-the-counter products are not
effective your dermatologist may
prescribe stronger prescription lotions
such as vitamin A which reduces the
build-up of dead skin cells in your
pores topical antibiotics which kill
bacteria on your skin or a combination
of benzoyl peroxide and topical
antibiotics for moderate to severe cases
your dermatologist may prescribe an oral
medication alone or in combination with
a topical treatment these medications
include oral antibiotics which kill
bacteria and reduce inflammation and
isotretinoin which is used only for the
most severe cases a corticosteroid
injection may be given to relieve your
pain and help clear up a particularly
large lesion for women
birth control pills containing estrogen
may be prescribed to minimize the
effects of testosterone regardless of
the treatment your doctor recommends
good skincare is essential for example
wash problem areas twice daily with a
mild soap and wash gently without
scrubbing if you have dry or peeling
skin use an oil-free water-based
moisturizer when choosing any product to
put on your skin look for an oil-free or
non comedogenic label which means it
won't clog your pores avoid picking or
squeezing blemishes as these actions may
lead to infection or scarring and avoid
touching your face with your hands your
hair or any object such as a cell phone